a dream come true we're talking about a
person facing the possibility of never
walking again Craig Dodson was shot
seven times while working as a security
guard that's right well after seven
surgeries and the possibility of never
being able to walk again today he's
standing tall as a new chapter and his
life begins the opening of a new
restaurant getting baked Candace Charles
sat down with him before the busy day
right now I'm about 130 maybe 150 baked
potato recipes oh my God Craig Dodson
loves potatoes fried baked broiled yeah
mashed potatoes french fries baked
potatoes so much so he opened a gourmet
Potato restaurant a dream he and his
wife kelly didn't think was possible
it's overwhelming to see him doing what
he was told he'd never be able to do
prior to becoming Chef Craig Dodson was
a security officer for more than 20
years including a stent with Blues King
BB King The King of the Blues come on
you can't beat that so I did that for
about 10 15 years until he passed his
career was cut short when tragedy struck
in December of 2014. I remember the
phone call like it was yesterday he was
working Security on the Strip when there
was a problem with a passenger who tried
to board an RTC bus in front of the
Paris Las Vegas hotel and casino 34 year
old Christopher Jean Bonino was taken
off the bus one thing led to another he
pulled his gun I pulled my gun and
unfortunately I
took his life Datsun was shot seven
times the tragedy League made him
physically and mentally scarred he never
wanted to take anyone's life he left the
profession seven surgeries and several
years later he turned to a dream he's
had since he was a child operating a
food truck I'm a fat kid from Memphis
and I like to eat this Thanksgiving he's
taking his dream to the next level
opening a 40-seat restaurant in the
Sundance Kid Cafe and of course potatoes
are on the menu we're actually doing a
build your own tux potato he tells me he
still thinks about the tragedy that led
him to where he is today I know I can't
bring that life back but
whatever I can do to help another life
uh that's that's what I try to do in
North Las Vegas I'm Candace Charles 8
News Now